nobody knows why the targaryens first
came to the island of Dragonstone old
valyria was then at the height of its
power and the center of the Civilized
World which ended at the narrow sea
Westeros was a filthy batwater with
seven Kings squabbling over borders and
minor glories
so much for progress
the island itself was and is nothing it
had no gold or gems to lure Valyrian
nobility all it has is rock mostly a
shiny black stone too brittle for war
and too sharp for building the
targaryens called it dragonglass
I call it useless but the targaryens
managed to raise a castle here
simpleton's claim they used ancient
Valyrian sorcery forgetting that the
targaryens brought a small army with
them from essos there's no magic in
strong backs though admittedly the
castle is unlike any in Westeros
foreign and
strange
you have to wait two years until the
next episode of House of the Dragon so
now is the perfect time for you to
listen to the audiobook on which house
of the Dragon is based and you can
listen to it now for free that's right
you can listen to Fire and Blood
audiobook for free it's a Targaryen
history book on which house of the
Dragon is based written by George R
Martin it goes from aegon's Conquest
until the end of the dance of the
Dragons which will also be the end of
House of the Dragon you can now listen
to it for free with horrible trial using
our link which you can find in the
description of this video all you have
to do is go to the description click the
link sign up for free audible trial and
choose Fire and Blood audiobook go and
listen to a long and Rich Targaryen
history including the current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
if the targaryens ever regretted their
Baron Outpost and longed for the
Comforts of home the Doom made their
Folly permanent
Valeria collapsed into the waves and was
no more
to look East was to see the ruin of
their Homeland the greatest civilization
before or since
but to look West
as aegon realized was to see a fertile
land ripe for Conquest
perhaps even a new valyria
though good for little else Dragonstone
was the perfect staging point for
aegon's invasion of Westeros the
Blackwater Bay granted easy access to
the continent the lands there were
disputed by Three Kingdoms the reach the
iron islands and stormlands but their
capitals were far enough away that none
could mount a force before aegon got a
foothold even if their kings had been
able to stop bickering over whose
problem he was
then it was too late
aegon had chosen his first Camp well
with the bay to the east the river to
the South and Open Fields to the north
and west his army would be impossible to
take by surprise a perfect sight for an
invasion and one day his capital city
King's Landing
aegon Targaryen landed to our South and
as had many before him like the look of
the riverlands my ancestor Edmund Tully
led the desertion of riverlords to his
cause and was rewarded by getting to
watch King haran burn in his own Tower
on the shores of the God's eye due north
of the Isle of faces
Rises a monument to arrogance and
cruelty
harrenhal
for a people who prided themselves on
their ships
the Iron Man of old seized any chance to
leave them
and carved out a vast Kingdom from the
peaceful River Lords
the Empire reached its Zenith under King
Heron hora
called the black by those he terrorized
and by his own men though they meant it
proudly
King Herron Enslaved the riverlands to
raise the mightiest Fortress Westeros
had ever seen a castle that could
Garrison a million men with walls so
vast that Winters would come and go and
besieging armies grew old and gray
before the castle fell five Towers he
ordered reaching into the heavens like
grasping fingers a monstrosity
which he forced our people to build for
their own subjugation
but the very day the slaves laid the
last Stone
aegon Targaryen and his sisters arrived
in the south
when they arrived with a small army
Herron laughed and shut the gates
Herron Hall would have its first test
and an easy one at that
it failed
Herron Hall could have withstood an
assault from all the armies in Westeros
combined but Herron learned that the
tallest and thickest walls meant little
to dragons
the dragons fly
the problem with huge castles is they
blind you to what's outside both by
their size and the arrogance they
inspire
not that the ironborn ever lacked for
that
they take pride in their ignorance of
every trapping of civilization
or any Baker could have told them that
fire turned stone walls into an oven
I'm so high on the black finally lived
up to his name and the river Lord swept
the ironborn Back to the Sea
when egg on the Conqueror came to the
iron Island the priest kingdodos claimed
his Divine father the ironborns Drowned
God had shown him kraken's pulling
aegon's ships into the deep
no Krakens ever arrived and even if they
had they wouldn't have stopped aegon and
his dragon without wings of Their Own
confused lodos filled his pockets with
stones and walked into the sea to take
counsel with his father
thousands followed him but apparently
the Drowned God didn't appreciate a
crowd
their corpse is washed upon the iron
Island for years
when aegon Targaryen declared that
Westeros was now his King myrn the ninth
allied with King Lauren Lannister of the
westerlands together they fought to save
Westeros from another foreign Barbarian
whose family practices were decent men
to shame
but the dragons won and the Field of
Fire claimed myrn and all his son's
grandsons and brothers
instead of using the castle for what it
was built to do Holland Tyrell
surrendered it to aegon without a fight
exchange Harlem was given the castle his
family had served for thousands of years
with all its attendant lands and Lords
for over a thousand years the green hand
sons and grandsons ruled the reach as
house Gardener the offshoots of his
daughters grew into fast and Powerful
houses in their own right except for
house Tyrell we chose instead to serve
our gardener cousins Faithfully as
stewards
to manage their stronghold of high
garden and the daily Affairs of the
reach
our words are growing strong
and under our stewardship the reach did
just that
as did we
until a blundering king almost cost us
everything
aegon Targaryen had landed in Westeros
King myrn Allied us with the rock to
repel the upstarts army
one can only Marvel that King myrn did
not reconsider when he saw the living
dragons against him
perhaps he should have sought counsel
from his trusted stewards before he set
out then again
perhaps he did
at the Field of Fire aegon and let us
not forget his sisters burnt the
combined armies of the reach and rock
King myrn paid for his misjudgment with
his life and that of his ancient family
in a day the reach had lost its king its
ruling house and most of its Army
thankfully for everyone my ancestor
Harlan Terrell had better sense until
the maesters sorted out the Intel among
man's cousins Harlan the steward was
acting Lord of highgarden
to ensure peace and life in the reach he
would yield the castle to aegon
the other castles and families would
then follow as they had since the dawn
age
had a continent to conquer
and the fertile reach was too valuable
to raise he accepted Harlan's proposal
and welcomed our lands into his kingdom
to show his gratitude aegon entitled
Harlan to highgarden
the castle his family had served for a
thousand years
and made house Tyrell his wardens of the
South choosing us over older greater
families in the reach
our house thus owed everything to the
targaryens
the Lannisters reigned as kings of the
rock for thousands of years and worked
to make it the Envy of the rest of the
Seven Kingdoms
our time as kings ended however when
aegon Targaryen otherwise known as aegon
the Conqueror arrived in Westeros with
his army
the last king of the rock King Lauren
Lannister joined forces with Kingman
Gardner the king of the reach together
with sixty thousand men they met the
Targaryen host in open battle
history tells us that aegon Unleashed
all three of his dragons slaughtering
four thousand men at what came to be
known as the Field of Fire
Kingman himself was burned alive that
day and house Gardener turned to Ash
with him
seeing both the threat and opportunity
the targaryens represented Lauren wisely
surrendered and aided aegon in his
further conquest of Westeros
the Lannisters were thus appointed
Lord's Paramount of the westerlands and
wardens of the West
titles we hold to this day
while aegon burnt the kings of the iron
Islands The Rock and the reach his
fiercest commander and rumored brother
or his Baratheon set out to subdue the
stormlands
no matter how Fierce a warrior he was no
one could have entered his task storms
ended since thousands of years of war
and never fallen but argalak the Storm
King chose not to barricade himself
behind its walls and gave always the
battle he must have hoped for
Aureus slew argonac and took argalak's
Castle Kingdom daughter sigil and house
words
house Baratheon became the lord of the
stormlands
when aegon and his dragons landed on
Westeros
the kings of The Rock and the reach sent
all their men to die to defend their
crowns
Torin start knelt to spare his people
the same fate
he placed Duty above Pride
the South had already fallen to aegon
and his dragons only the north remained
my ancestor King tauren Stark marched
the north down to the Trident and beheld
aegon's army larger than torn's owned by
half and with three dragons circling
overhead many Northern Bannerman wanted
to attack anyway claiming Northern Valor
would carry the day
others wanted to fall back to moat Kalin
and make her stand there
but tauren had heard how the armies of
The Rock and the reach had burned on the
field of fire and had seen the fires
still glowing beneath the rubble of
harrenhal he knelt and laid his ancient
Crown at aegon's feet and Rose a king no
more but Lord of Winterfell and Warden
of the North
some Northerners still sneer at my
ancestors the king who knelt forgetting
that because of tauren they're alive
today to sneer their ancestors didn't
leave their burned bones at the Trident
and their Twisted swords didn't fill
aegon's new throne
no Army in the Seven Kingdoms can match
the pride and chivalry of the Knights of
the veil after all they were the first
true knights in Westeros until the
dragons changed the game
when aegon the Conqueror landed in
Westeros
the queen regent of the vale shut the
bloody gate against the tagarians and
masts the Knights of the veil behind it
to lock it but for Sania simply flew her
Dragon to a balcony of the Eerie where
the boy King was playing
wide round the castle
in return for his mother's submission
when aegon the Conqueror landed in
Westeros the high septon locked himself
in a sept for seven days and seven
nights
finally the Crone lifted her golden lamp
and showed him the path ahead the high
septon himself would anoint and Crown
aegon as lord of the Seven Kingdoms and
the faith militant rallied behind aegon
in governing his newly United land
yet aegon and his sisters never wholly
accepted the faith the high septum had
conceded aegon's marriages to his
sisters as a relic of his Valerian
Heritage which would soon fade
aegon Targaryen sought to unite Westeros
as nymeria had Dorne the other six
kingdoms fell quickly before his dragons
and ambition when his sister wife
rhaenys flew her Dragon South and
demanded our surrender as well princess
media Martel warned I will not fight you
nor will I kneel to you Dorne has no
King tell your brother that
rainies threatened that the next time
the targaryens would come with Fire and
Blood Maria replied
you may burn us my lady but you will not
Bend us break us or make us bow this is
Dorne you are not wanted here return at
your peril
rain is dead and she died her Dragon
died
all her soldiers died eventually her
brother the Conqueror conceded that what
nymeria had done he could not undo
Generations later another foolish
Targaryen invaded Dorne he died as well
eventually we did join the Seven
Kingdoms but when we wanted and on our
terms two years until season two is a
long period but you can still stay in
the house of the Dragon World by
listening to Fire and Blood audiobook
for free house of the Dragon is based on
Fire and Blood book and covers the
entire Targaryen history starting from
aegon the Conqueror and his Conquest as
well as Meg or the cruel and other
legendary targaryens including the
current and future events of House of
the Dragon go and listen to it for free
with horrible trial using our Link in
the description
foreign